dr zakiyah several hadiths and
historical accounts say that the quran
was revealed over a period of 23 years
is there an apparent contradiction
between that and what the quran says
that was revealed
in one night in leidenfield qatar there
is no contradiction
between the hadith
and the historical records
and the quran
because
if you read the tafseer of the quran
that the quran was revealed in life
it means that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
he revealed the quran from
foos from the preserved tablet to the
lower heaven
on the light of father
that is
in the night of power in one night
and then
from that lower heaven
parts of the quran few verses at a time
was revealed whenever required in a span
of 23 history years in a span of 23
lunar years or in a span of 22 and four
to five solar years
so there's no apparent contradiction it
was revealed one night from the tablet
preserved to the lower end and from
there as in time required was revealed
in parts and verses and surah wise in a
span of 23 years okay thank you clearing
up that apparent contradiction and and
similarly as far as the qatar is
concerned
that allah
has in his knowledge
everything
what's going to happen
past present future
and
from that
tablet
he reveals in the night of qatar to the
angels whatever is going to happen in
the next year from this side of the
other to the next night it's
so the angels come to know everything
was going to happen in the next one year
in this night
but in allah's knowledge it is there
till eternity
okay
thank you for clearing up that apparent
contradiction dr zaki